nyt CCP BTC is
what capital communist Capital crypto
capital and communist capital is the
simplest is you must submit the
Communist party is powerful CCP is
powerful and you are not if you're in
China you just CCP is an embodiment of
communist Capital that you're talking
about well yeah so basically and by the
in China they call it CPC you know so
basically they don't like it usually if
you say CCP right so uh like Communist
Party of China as opposed to Chinese
kind of sort of there basically that is
capitalism that is uh that it's a
Chinese pool of capital that billion
person pool okay that that's WeChat and
it's
um you know it's Alibaba and its entire
kind of thing that is one just social
network with currency the whole thing's
vertically enjoyable when we say
communist what do you mean here what was
the word communist important why don't
you just say China so it's it's
communist an important one well it's
just a catchy label it's a casual but I
think it's also important because it
seems It's paradoxical right it's at a
threat on this
the future is communist Capital versus
Capital versus crypto Capital each
represents a left right Fusion that's
Bizarre by the standards of the 1980s
consensus it's PRC versus mmt versus BTC
all right and why is it Bizarre by the
standards the 1980s consensus well in
the 1980s you wouldn't think the
Communists would become capitalists but
they did you wouldn't think that the
wokes the progressives right
um would become so enamored with giant
corporations and and their power right
they've seen something to to liken that
right
um and you also wouldn't think that the
non-americans or the post-americans or
the internationalists would be the
champions of capital because
um you think it's the American Nation
right so rather than the conservative
American nationalists
being the Defenders of capital
you have the
liberal
Americans who are with capital you have
the Communist Chinese or with capital
and you have the internationalists who
are with capital and it's the
conservative American nationalists who
are in some ways against that which is
which is kind of funny right so uh so
it's like this weird ideological
flipping that
um if you if you look if you take the
long lens you have these polls that kind
of repel each other okay so just on the
CCP nyt BTC thing
nyt by the way is Wolf Capital yeah what
is nyt so its formula is a little
interesting if CCP is just you must
submit because they're powerful okay and
then you bow your head because the
Chinese Communist party is strong well
capital is you must sympathize why do
you bow your head Lex oh because you're
a white male therefore you're guilty you
sympathize you must bow your head
because you are powerful
yet notice it ends in the same place in
your your head looking to the ground
right in China it's because they are
powerful so therefore you must bend your
head
for the books it's the left-handed
version where you are powerful and
that's shameful so you should bow your
head
right right okay but it ends in your
head bowed it's an ideology of
submission it's not that subtle but it's
like somewhat subtle then finally crypto
capital is head held high you must be
sovereign
okay which and one of the things I point
out in the in the book is each of these
polls
is
um negative in some ways when taken to
extreme but also negative in its
opposite for example
obviously just totally submitting to
Total surveillance is bad but a society
where nobody submits is San Francisco
where people just Rob stores and walk
out you know in the middle shoplifting
you know all this all these goods and
nothing happens right a society where
you know you have the vocal level of
sympathy where you get to the kind of
insanity of math is white supremacist
and whatever you know nonsense is is
happening today is terrible but a
society that's totally stripped of
sympathy is also not one that one would
want to be part of right that's just
like the
you know whether it's 4chan's actual
culture or its feign culture or
something like that or some some weird
combination you that's also not good
it's like Russia in the 90s like nobody
trusts anybody that's also bad
and you know being totally Sovereign
that sounds good and there's a lot that
is good about it and I'm sympathetic to
this corner but being totally Sovereign
you go so capitalist so Sovereign that
you're against the division of labor you
don't trust anybody so you have to pump
your own water and so on so you actually
have a reduced standard of living over
here okay
and conversely survivalist or whatever
survivalist type stuff right and you
just kind of you you just go kind of too
crazy into that corner and then like of
course though the Other Extreme of you
know having no sovereignty is the you
will own nothing and be happy
everything's in the cloud and can be
deleted at any point right so each of
these is kind of has Badness when it's
there but also it's total extreme
opposite is bad and so you want to kind
of carve out like an intelligent
intermediate of these three poles and
that's the you know decentralized center
of the recentralized center I call now
with that said
I think there is a repositioning in
particular of vote Capital that is
happening and I think if the 2000s was
the global war on terror and then the
channel just changed to wokeness in the
2010s and I mean channel change have you
seen Paul Graham's graph or actually
David rosado's graph that Paul Graham
posted no but this is a good chance to
say that Paul Graham is awesome okay
yeah and so here is this graph okay
David rosado's data analysis I think
that put this together so but basically
this is a graph of the word usage
frequency New York Times 1970 to 2018
and he's got some controls there Paul
Graham tweets hypothesis although some
newspapers can survive the switch to
online subscriptions none can do it and
remain politically neutral quote
newspaper or record you have to pick a
side to get people to subscribe and
there's uh
a bunch of
plots
on the x-axis is years on the y-axis is
the frequency of use
and sexism has been going up misogyny
has been going up sexist
patriarchy Mass planning toxic
masculinity male privilege all these
terms have been going up
very intensely in the past in in the in
the past decade yeah but really 2013 is
the exact moment you see these things
they're flat and they just go vertical
mansplaining toxic masculinity what
precisely happened in 2013. ah so
I talked about this in the book but I
think fundamentally what happened was
Tech hurt media and their revenue
dropped by uh about 50 billion dollars
over the four years from oh 2012. Tech
helped Obama get reelected and media was
positive on on Tech until December 2012
they wrote like the Nerds Go Marching In
in the Atlantic then after January 2013
once Obama was ensconced then the knives
came out because basically these Tech
guys were bankrupting them they were
through
um supporting them and so the journals
got extremely nasty and uh just
basically they couldn't build search
engines or create social networks but
they could write stories in shape
narrators so clear editorial Direction
went down that
um you know essentially took all of this
all these weapons that had been
developed in Academia to win status
competitions and Humanities departments
yeah and and then they just deployed
them right and essentially somebody
observed that wokeness is the
combination of uh focality and
deconstruction and civil rights where
deconstruction takes away you know the
legitimacy of the old order and then
civil rights says okay the only thing
that's good is is this right which is
says the older is also bad in a
different way but this is what's good
and um
that is the underpinning ideology the
the all these words have embedded in
them like in ideology right another way
of thinking about it is
this is not my reference but outside
anyway the glossary of the Greek
um military Junta right the creation and
or use of special terms are employed by
the juntas propaganda tools
um because essentially the word itself
embeds a concept you can Russell
conjugate something one way or the other
right Russell conjugation is this
concept that I sweat you perspire but
She Glows you can always take something
you know you are uncontrollably angry
but uh he is righteously indignant okay
um you have a thin skin they clap back
right so once you kind of realize that
these words have just been chosen in
such a way as to delegitimize their
Target and they all went vertical in
2013 and they were suddenly targeted
against the erstwhile alleys you know in
Tech but also just across the the
country you can see that this great
awokening that's what uh Iglesias called
it by plan where it's the Great
Awakening right this kind of spasm of
quasi-religious extremism I wouldn't
call it religious because it's not
god-centered it's release date and
network centered so I call it a Doctrine
which is a superset of religion and
political Doctrine this uh these words
went vertical and the all the terrorism
stuff you just noticed kind of fell off
the cliff that was the obsession of
everything in the 2000s
and just channel change right it's
amazing how that happened yeah it's not
like not like any of the pieces got
picked up some of those Wars are still
raging of course and there's uh victims
to this wilkism movement and um but in a
weird way even though some parts of it
just like you know Siri like there's
wars in the Middle East that still keep
raging there's there's certainly active
fronts of vocalism you know but in a
sense the the next shift is already on
you know why
it's a pivot for mochism to statism
in many ways nyt is sort of and more
generally the U.S establishment is sort
of kind of coming you may not believe
this they're kind of coming back to the
center a little bit and the same with
that Lenin After the revolution
implemented the New Economic Policy
which you may be aware of right which
was just like X percent more capitalism
you kind of boot on the neck take
control but then ease up for a bit and
the so-called net men during the 20s
were able to eke out something there was
like you know oh okay fine he's going to
be easier on us then an intense fight
again because basically by loosening up
they were able to consolidate control
they weren't putting as much pressure on
right then it went extremely intense
again right uh similar to like Mao's
like 100 flowers saying let a hundred
flowers bloom and you know everybody
came out and then you found out all the
people who were against him and he
executed a bunch of them right so what's
happening now is nyt is and more
generally just establishment is somewhat
tacking back to the center where you
know they're not talking BLM and abolish
the police they're saying fund the
Capitol Police right they've they've
gone from The Narrative of 2020 which
was meant to win a domestic contest
where they said America's a systemically
racist country tear down George
Washington we're so evil to the red
record 2022 which is we're the global
champion of democracy and every
non-white country is supposed to trust
us
now
obviously those are inconsistent right
if if you're in India or you're in
Nigeria and you just heard that the
America is calling itself the same guys
by the way saying it's so
institutionally racist systemically
racist and you're saying well we're the
leader of the Free World and the number
one obviously there's inconsistency
between the domestic propaganda and the
foreign propaganda right there's a
contrast between abolish the police and
put two billion for the capital police
you can reconcile this and you can say
the use establishment is pro-federal and
anti-local and state so abolish the
local police who tend to be you know
Republican or rightist but fund the FBI
fund the capital police who tend to be
you know just like in the
um you know Soviet Union as a national
things like the the KGB right that were
there for the um uh for the state
um but there are all these local
nationalist ethnic insurgencies and like
Estonia and other places right so you
can reconcile them but nevertheless on
its face those those are contradictory
so what are you going to get I think I
think you're going to get
um this rotation where uh a fair number
of the folks on the sort of
authoritarian right are kind of pulled
back into the fold a bit okay these are
the cops and the military and whatnot
some of them because as this decade
progresses you're going to see the
signaling on American statism as opposed
to wilkism okay which is 30 degrees back
towards the center right conversely on
the other side you're going to have the
left Libertarians and right Libertarians
who are signaling crypto and
decentralization and so on okay and so
the next one isn't red versus blue it's
Orange versus green it's the dollar
versus Bitcoin and so you have the
authoritarians the top of the political
Compass versus the quote Libertarians
right and here is the here's the visual
of that
so that's why like you know as I wrote
the book and after I was like you know
I'm already seeing this
um this shift happening from war on
terror to bokism to American statism
right and here just take a look at this
visual
interesting so uh the visual is an
animation transforming
the
left versus right libertarian versus
authoritarian to uh
Bitcoin dollar versus versus crypto
that's right and some folks switch sides
right because you have folks Like You
Know Jack Dorsey and a lot of the tech
Founders in basically lower left corner
right who were blue but are now going to
become orange or are orange and you have
folks in the upper right corner who are
going to at the end of the day pick the
dollar and the American flag over the
internationalist ideals of
cryptocurrency the realigning as you
call it